for a long time
the american right wing has been using
their narrow and myopic
cartoonish outdated view of masculinity
and femininity to attack anybody they
can on the left of course uh you might
remember back in the 2004 presidential
election a big narrative a big movement
was feminized john kerry john kerry was
the democratic presidential nominee in
2004 running against george w bush who
was the republican running for
reelection and the story was bush is
masculine he clears brush with a
chainsaw in texas he throws a baseball
well and on the other hand the storyline
from these right-wingers was john kerry
is feminine because he windsurfed
spoke french imagine
speaking another language now is
feminine and once sort of fumbled the
football that was thrown to him and of
course this in and of itself didn't
really fit the facts the facts were
kerry was the military veteran who
served in combat in vietnam
bush was able to be barely involved in
the military thanks to family
connections by their own standards
kerry should have been seen as the
masculine one but it didn't matter the
tactic is you feminize the person in the
democratic party but okay that was 2004.
we hadn't really seen this tactic during
covid
except for the occasional uh wearing a
mask is gay type of stuff that we've
previously covered on the show
they are now really upping the ante on
that talking point
fox news propagandist tucker carlson
during an interview with british
right-winger nigel farage
said that getting covered
not getting the vaccine getting coveted
you get sick with kobit
it feminizes you it makes you more like
a woman
let's take a look at the clip bishop
quality
yes we're going to go and climb that
hill
and here's why we want to do it and we
invite you the public to come with us on
that journey amen that is leadership and
boris just with the best one in the
world doesn't have that and
we've seen more u-turns in policy from
the johnson government than i've seen in
any government in my lifetime yes and uh
in a very embarrassing way oh some of
it's been shocking so somebody who knows
him told me and i i was initially
getting your take on this that getting
kovid
emasculated him it changed him it we it
feminized him and weakened him
as a man do you think that's well i
think he was very seriously ill for
one of the things we have learned from
covid is people who are 50 60 70 80
pounds overweight
tend to have fed very badly sure now we
don't talk about it but the virus itself
this is true
does tend to take away the life force in
some people i know this i mean it does
feminize people i no one ever says that
but it's true i
look i think the virus did affect him
but i think let's be honest about it
it's it's the new wife isn't it i mean
yeah it's you know carrie johnson or as
she's now called carrie antoinette
which the historians like now of course
if this is true
if getting sick from covid is feminine
all those right-wing radio hosts who
denounced the vaccine didn't get
vaccinated ultimately got covered and
died
that's very very feminine by this metric
that tucker carlson is laying out for us
i actually got hit with this first hand
i don't know how many of you remember
a few years ago i fainted on an airplane
sort of a i've fainted a few times in my
life just sort of a
combination of dehydration elevation
coffee alcohol you know bad combination
of stuff and when i told the story
some people commented on youtube what a
[ __ ]
and others said it was a medical event
you know like it's not uh it's not
feminine or masculine it's just a
medical reality and that's essentially
the same thing that tucker is doing here
now there's one other funny thing about
this
these right wingers don't apply this
standard to their own
none of them said
feminized herman cain what a woman when
he got coveted and died he was a friend
of trump he was a republican
a jordan peterson has been in and out of
all sorts of treatments for what near
two years now i guess he's out now but
he was in for close to a couple years
hospitals in eastern europe etc they
never said how feminine of jordan
peterson and in fact he still had his
fans and acolytes hanging on his every
word so as usual
it's a silly idea it's a dumb idea
disease as feminine is being sick as
feminine but they also only apply it
when it's convenient to their narrative
i actually do think
maybe some of you would disagree major
progress has been made on on some of
this stuff
and
fortunately more of the population in
the u.s
don't see
this bizarre narrow definition of
masculinity as relevant you know men hug
more now in u.s culture than before
it's been no big deal in most cultures
for a long time in the u.s there was
more of a that's that's gay man um but
that it's diminished to some degree so i
i actually think on this particular
issue
um some progress has been made
but it still persists in many many
places and as usual it's the
hypocritical application of these
standards that's particularly
nonsensical so no real surprise
i i genuinely don't think tucker
believes any of this stuff and you and i
meaning people in the audience have
called in before to talk about is tucker
for real is he pretending the anti-vac
stuff he's certainly vaccinated right
i'm sure all his family was vaccinated
the first day they became eligible i
don't know
but my instinct is
i think tucker's a terrible person
because he's willing to do this stuff
but i'm leaning towards it's all bs i
don't really think he believes
more than half of these nonsense talking
points that he comes up with i think
it's for the show i think it's
performative i think it's for ratings
and that's nothing i would ever do you
all know if i tell you something on this
show it's actually what i believe let me
know what you think you can find me on
twitter at d pacman is tucker for real
with these talking points or are they
just performative
also remember that tomorrow is the last
and final david pakman show viewer town
hall of the year
6 p.m eastern 3 p.m pacific tuesday
december 14th it'll be streaming live on
the pacman live youtube channel and if
you want to participate you can get
connected on the david pakman show
discord at davidpakman.com
discord
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too right now chili sleep is
running a special sale you'll get 30 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video